hablemos de economía en france 24 con
nuestro periodista jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido y empecemos por el tema del
día el mes de guerra en ucrania como
esto ha impactado a la economía de rusia
bueno te menciono rápidamente en los
alimentos al menos han aumentado en un
14% desde que inició la invasión rusa en
ucrania la importación de bienes se ha
visto afectada principalmente por la
pérdida del valor del rublo la moneda ha
caído en un 22% en lo que va de este año
la inflación ya supera el 12% y es la
más alta desde 2015 productos como el
azúcar subieron un 37% en algunas
regiones y la cebolla es un 13% las
autoridades reconocen que la contracción
económica provocará un aumento del
desempleo y probablemente un reclamo
social casi 60.000 rusos perdieron el
trabajo debido a las sanciones en marzo
según los datos oficiales y luego de los
primeros días de la invasión la farmacia
tenemos que mostrar una escasez de
insulina y al menos otros 80 fármacos el
mercado de valores de rusia volvió a
operar el día de hoy luego de que se
desplomara tras la invasión el gobierno
ruso busca comprar acciones para dar
confianza en 2020 rusia era la undécima
economía del mundo según el banco
mundial pero a finales de este año es
posible que no ocupe un lugar más alto
que el número 15 antes de la guerra de
rusia tenía la calificación crediticia
de grado de inversión con las tres
principales agencias s&p global moody's
y fitch está esta calificación maria
clara lo que significa básicamente es
que este país puede acceder a préstamos
accesibles y con intereses bajos ahora
es el país con mayores recortes de la
historia de calificación crediticia lo
que indica un riesgo inminente de impago
hoy la conferencia de las naciones
unidas para el comercio del desarrollo
estimó que la economía rusa caerá un 7
3% este año como consecuencia de las
sanciones de occidente y jorgé el g7 y
la unión europea pusieron restricciones
al oro ruso como sirva esto así es bueno
esto básicamente lo que busca es que
rusia nueva las sanciones
internacionales que ha impuesto
occidente el bloque europeo y el g7
acordaron restringir las transacciones
del oro del banco central de rusia
la capacidad de rusia para aliviar el
impacto de las sanciones es uno de los
principales objetivos de las potencias
mundiales las primeras sanciones ya han
hecho caer la moneda rusa hasta los 130
rublos por dólar desde los 80 rublos por
dólar antes de la invasión una de las
medidas con más efecto fue la
congelación de la mitad de las reservas
del banco central ruso pero el g7
reconoce que el efecto inmediato de la
guerra es la presión para la seguridad
alimentaria y piden que las sanciones
adoptadas contra rusia tengan en cuenta
la necesidad de evitar un impacto global
en el comercio agroalimentario y ahora
hablemos de la conferencia de la onu
para el comercio y el desarrollo que
también brindó su previsión de
crecimiento para américa latina así que
si el organismo lo que hizo fue bajar
esta perspectiva de crecimiento en tres
décimas para nuestra región la economía
latinoamericana crecerá un 2,3 por
ciento en 2022 esto como consecuencia
directa de la guerra de eeuu cram ya la
subida de precios del combustible y
elementos podrían beneficiar a naciones
exportadoras de materias primas como
argentina colombia o chile por esto el
organismo revisó su previsión para el
cono sur y lo ubicó en 4 6 asimismo
mejoró su pronóstico de crecimiento para
centroamérica y el caribe que pasó del 2
9% de hace medio año al 35 aunque bajó
un punto y medio de sus perspectivas
para méxico también alertaron de una
fuerte desaceleración que podría
producirse en brasil por la agresiva
política monetaria y en argentina por la
deuda externa y vamos a europa donde el
bloque de los veintisiete aprobó la ley
antimonopolio para los gigantes de
internet qué consiste esto afectará a
empresas como google apple meta o amazon
que probablemente tendrán que cambiar su
modelo de negocio en los próximos años
el bloque aprobó hoy el texto definitivo
de la ley de mercados digitales que
entrará en vigor en 2023 y que va a
regular las tiendas de aplicaciones
móvil se lee las búsquedas en internet y
restringe el uso de los gigantes de
internet sobre los datos personales la
normativa prohíbe a las empresas
combinar los datos personales que
adquieren de los usuarios a través de
sus múltiples servicios por ejemplo me
que me está cruce la información que
obtiene de su servicio de mensajería
whatsapp y cuáles son los indicadores
bueno wall street cerró en verde por el
rebote tecnologías y en especial por los
fabricantes de microprocesadores en
europa el dax 40 de fráncfort no pudo
mantener las ganancias con las que
inició la sesión y cerró con ligeras
pérdidas por las tensiones de la guerra
en ucrania y en américa latina la bolsa
de sao paulo se llevó su sexta subida
consecutiva impulsada por los grandes
valores como petrobras y vale gracias
jorge y a ustedes gracias por
sintonizarnos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
i
[Música]